en este vídeo veremos cómo completar el
cuadrado entonces veamos la solución
para la ecuación cuadrática x cuadrada
menos 6 x + 8 y miren sin duda podemos
factorizar esta ecuación fácilmente pero
lo que yo quiero es que entendamos el
procedimiento entonces veamos el camino
largo lo primero que tienen que hacer es
observar los términos que contienen x
que serían estos y lo que queremos es
que el coeficiente de x cuadrada sea
igual a 1 que en este caso lo es pero en
caso de que no lo fuera tendríamos que
factorizar entonces en este caso si se
cumple esta condición ok y lo que
hacemos después es poner entre
paréntesis a los términos que contienen
x dejando un pequeño espacio y después
escribimos más 8 igual a 0 entonces la
forma en la que podemos completar el
cuadrado es que cualquier número que
tengamos antes d
es decir el coeficiente de este término
que en este caso es menos 6 bueno a este
número lo vamos a dividir entre 2
entonces menos 6 entre 2 es menos 3 y
después a este número lo elevamos al
cuadrado y lo ponemos en el espacio así
que en este caso obtenemos 9 positivo ok
entonces estamos agregando un número
nuevo que no estaba ahí antes agregamos
el número 9 que antes no estaba ahí ok y
bueno en este caso la forma en la que
nos podemos deshacer de eso es que bueno
imaginen que al deshacernos del
paréntesis regresamos a la ecuación que
teníamos originalmente excepto que ahora
tendríamos más 9 entonces para cancelar
lo vamos a restar 9 de este lado ok y
observen que esto ocurre del lado
izquierdo de la igualdad y bueno ahora
simplemente simplificamos todo esto lo
podemos escribir entre paréntesis
como un cuadrado perfecto y de hecho lo
podemos factorizar como x
3 x x 3 ok entonces al número que sea
que tengamos como coeficiente en el
término x lo dividimos entre 2 en este
caso nos dio menos 3 y eso elevado al
cuadrado es lo que ponemos en los
paréntesis entonces más 8 menos 9 es
menos 1 y eso es igual a 0 ahora vamos a
escribir la primera parte como x menos
tres al cuadrado y después menos uno
igual a cero ok entonces queremos
resolver una ecuación cuadrática y una
vez que llegamos a este punto bueno en
este caso simplemente vamos a sumar 1 en
ambos lados de la ecuación y así nos
queda x menos 3 al cuadrado igual a 1
positivo y bueno la finalidad de
resolver una ecuación cuadrática
completando el cuadrado es que podamos
llegar hasta este punto porque
ahora lo que podemos hacer es aplicar la
raíz cuadrada en ambos lados entonces
tenemos raíz cuadrada de x menos 3 al
cuadrado y eso es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 1 y al colocar la raíz
cuadrada en este lado debemos escribir
más menos ahora del lado izquierdo como
teníamos todo al cuadrado
nos queda x menos 3 y eso es igual a más
o menos 1 ya tenemos nuestras dos
ecuaciones vamos a separarlas vamos a
ver tenemos que resolver una de las
ecuaciones que es x menos 3 igual a uno
positivo y la otra ecuación que es x
menos 3 igual a menos 1 ok y luego
simplemente sumamos 3 en los dos casos y
nos queda que una de nuestras soluciones
es x igual a 4 positivo y si sumamos
tres en la segunda ecuación nos queda x
igual a 2
y podemos verificar estas soluciones al
sustituirlas en la ecuación original y
comprobando que obtenemos 0 este fue
nuestro ejemplo